today i have the pleasure of being with
steve kaufman steve grew up in the
english english-speaking region of
montreal canada and he's a graduate of
leicester city politik de paris also
known as cion spo in parrot in france
and he's a former canadian diplomat uh
founder of link.com and he runs a
company involved in the international
wood products trade
his blog the linguist on language is
dedicated to his language learning
passion
steve speaks about 14 languages
he's a regular contributor to
the language learning community on the
web he has a lot of videos on youtube
for example
and steve has been a huge inspiration to
me in the past couple of years i've
followed him
for many years and he's always
he's always very very open about
the strategies he uses for language
learning and today we're going to ask
him about um his opinion on whether
learning languages is a hard thing and
what we can do to make it a little bit
easier so steve thank you so much for
your time thank you for being here today
my pleasure nice to talk to you so how
are you today
i'm very well thank you
okay so i'm going to be it's not raining
here in vancouver
so
same area in ottawa we do have some some
finally some nice weather although it
was a pretty cold winter so
so i will be asking you a few questions
uh if you're fine with that um and
that's going to be surrounding the topic
of uh language learning difficulty and
whether it's hard to learn a language
and what we can do to make it easier
so um first of all a lot of people are
afraid to learn a language or they just
will never do it because they've been
told it's something that is just too
difficult
so really just how difficult is it to
learn a foreign language in your opinion
and why
well you know it's funny i had a
question on my youtube channel from
someone who said you know why is
learning a language so difficult
that's what kind of got me thinking
about the subject
um i don't think it's necessarily
difficult
uh if we go to countries like sweden
uh most of the population speaks english
possibly another language
in singapore most the population speaks
two or three languages
uh
i've never thought that people in sweden
or singapore were born with a special
language learning gene
but they have a different attitude they
just think it's something that
quite naturally i'm going to do i have
to do everyone does
uh and i think uh
people who consider language are
difficult and i shouldn't say it's not
just that they consider it difficult
it's that they've actually had
difficulty
vast majority of people who study
languages particularly in north america
and maybe quebec is a bit of a different
situation there because i think there's
greater motivation to learn english in
quebec
than to learn other languages in other
parts of north america
uh so most of them find it difficult why
i think there's a number of reasons one
because their expectations maybe are out
of whack
they think that they can just pick up a
book
uh leave through some declension tables
or try to study them
should be able to start speaking
and in short order
you know they should be able to speak
quite well
that's just not how it works
uh you need massive exposure to the
language
uh the swedes for example they're
watching english television from a very
early age
um
they don't learn english because they
don't do anything differently in schools
from what we do
you know they do the same they study
grammar that's not where they that's not
where they learn they learn because they
have this massive exposure so i think a
lot of people underestimate the amount
of time you actually have to spend with
the language
and so they go at it in a way that's
that's quite difficult with a lot of
focus on things that are inherently
difficult and
and uninteresting like trying to
memorize declension tables or
conjugation tables is very difficult
um
so i mean if you're prepared to put in
the time and i notice on some of your
blog posts you emphasize the importance
of enjoying the process
so if you're prepared to put in the time
and if you can find a way to enjoy the
process
then i don't think language learning is
difficult
so it's all about enjoying yourself and
getting to know yourself more as a
learner would you say it's about that
i think it's about
not being too concerned about how much
you can say at the beginning how well
you can say things
but rather
accepting the fact that you're going to
have to gradually get used to the
language
and that your initial focus
should be
to understand the language and to
acquire a lot of words here again as i
was reading through your blog this whole
idea that with five percent of the words
you can understand 90 i've never found
that to be the case
um i've as i learned right now i'm
learning ukrainian
i've learned so many different languages
even after you have a fairly large
vocabulary
because a lot of the key words you don't
have
you can't make sense of what's being
said you may know the words go come of
the
because i you he
you know all of the most common words
that account for 70 80
but you actually need a large vocabulary
in order
and so you have to acquire that through
this process of lots of listening and
reading
and
for those people who don't enjoy doing
that then language learning can be
difficult unless they want to limit
themselves to being able to say hello
how are you my name is but if you
actually want to achieve some degree of
fluency
you have to put in time but
the secret is to find a way to put in
the time that you find enjoyable you
know
i find for example if i compare language
learning to improving my golf claim
i know that all the time i put into
language learning is going to give me a
return the more time i put in the better
i'm going to get that's not true of golf
because not everyone can hit a golf ball
you know not everyone's going to be a
figure skater not everyone is going to
be a great i don't know artist so there
are so many things that are genuinely
difficult where no matter how no matter
how much time i put into drawing or
singing i'm never going to be good at
drawing or singing i know that because
it takes very very specific you know
talent aptitude
but in language learning i think anyone
who puts in the time
uh exposing themselves to the language
gradually starting to talk they're going
to improve
so to me from that perspective it's not
necessarily difficult
i don't know so you believe that uh for
activities like drawing or singing you
do need a particular attitude but not
for language learning
yeah let's put it this way i think you
need aptitude in both but i think the
the uh factor
aptitude is less important
everyone in sweden can speak english
so i don't believe they have a special
gene
but i don't think everybody in sweden is
good at drawing
so to some extent presumably if you're
not going to sing you can improve
but
uh
i mean the difference is like we all
more or less speak our own language
uh if we look at sports obviously some
people are more gifted than others
you know and we see kids that play
hockey or whatever and they all put in
the same amount of time and some kids
become stars and superstars and other
kids don't
whereas i think in language a far
greater number of people can achieve a
high level of proficiency if they put in
the time and if they learn in a in a
effective way
and speaking of language difficulty so
that's my second question here
from your own experience has language
learning become considerably easier as
you got to know yourself better as a
language learner and as you gain
experience learning languages
oh no question
i mean i'm a far better language learner
today
than i was back
when i was a 16 year old
uh i have more confidence and that's
important another reason why people find
language learning difficult is because
they don't think they're going to
achieve fluency they've never done it
before
so once i achieved genuine fluency in
french then i felt confident that i
could do it in other languages so i have
a conference i've done it so now i have
an approach to language learning that i
know works at least works for me
so i don't waste my time and then the
other big thing is just the explosion of
of convenient technology i mean the mp3
player the availability of of uh
of resources on the internet i mean for
every language that i've wanted to learn
over the last 10 years i mean the amount
of stuff on the internet is phenomenal
and i can carry it around with me in my
little ipod manual
i listen to it
so and link of course the technology
that we have have there i used to have
to
deliberately find textbooks readers that
have glossaries in them
because i wasn't going to go looking
words up in a dictionary it's simply too
time consuming and as soon as you close
the dictionary you've forgotten what you
looked up anyway
so i would look i would scour
secondhand bookstores for these readers
with with glossaries but now you don't
need to do that
because you can use online dictionaries
you can access anything so there's no
question that it is far easier that i
personally first of all as a person i'm
a better language learner but that the
whole environment for language learning
has made it much much easier than it was
40 50 years ago
so
you know in to sum it all up if people
use the right tools and if they gain
experience and they get to know
themselves better as a language learner
language learner language learning
itself is going to become easier there's
no no doubt about this it becomes easier
and and even within your first language
if you haven't done it before as you get
going you gain more confidence
again as long as it so this whole issue
of difficulty relates to expectations if
your expectation is that within a very
short time you can speak fluently you're
going to be disappointed but if your
expectation is that you can
enjoy the language more and more as you
understand more and more of it that you
get a sense of power
and achievement as you acquire more
words as things that were unintelligible
to you before now become clearer and
clearer even though that they remain a
little foggy and that's language
learning but they become clearer and
clearer to you
then with that confidence
obviously you know how the brain works
if you get a sense of achievement you
want to do more of that because you
you're mastering something that's just a
little difficult for you but you're
getting there
so uh and and i think as people gain
that sense of confidence then they will
the even the first language becomes
easier and subsequently additional
languages become easy i'm sure you've
had that experience yeah totally but i
would also add that at the other end of
the spectrum if you start learning you
start off learning a language with the
idea that you're never going to be able
to do it it's just too hard it's
impossible
that's not going to work either
way no way so you have to have realistic
expectations about you know learning a
language how hard it is or how easy it
is and you have to believe in yourself
be confident that you can do it and yet
not have unrealistic expectations that
you can either become fluent in a matter
of weeks or that you you're never going
to be able to do it
yeah the thing is it's not difficult but
it takes time and when i talk about
realistic expectations i mean about the
amount of time it takes
that's what you have to be realistic
but it's not difficult it's just a
matter of putting in the time
in terms of difficulty now that we're on
the subject and you speak of time
have you found that some languages are
considerably harder than others for
example you've been interested
in korean as of recently how how are you
finding korean compared to say spanish
or or german well there are a number of
factors that will influence the
difficulty of a language the first one
because i'm very much vocabulary
oriented if you have a language say
spanish and english that share 50
the same vocabulary obviously it's
easier for an english speaker to learn
spanish than to learn korean because in
korean you have to learn every word from
scratch so you have nothing to identify
with nothing which is it's much more
difficult to remember words that have
there's nothing you can relate it to
so obviously okay
languages that are of this even if
they're not of the same language group
like
chinese and japanese
but they share 50 of the same vocabulary
so you have an advantage so that's one
thing the other thing that makes a
language difficult is the complexity of
the grammar
in that sense slavic languages i find
difficult
uh
because
in korean there's a lot there are a lot
of endings different endings to words
but there is there are logical reasons
for those endings so therefore it's
easier to remember
whereas
the declension tables in in russian
there's no rhyme or reason as to why it
should be
there's no particular reason you know
the genitive feminine doesn't suggest e
whereas the gen and the masculine
suggests ah there's no rational reason
so you have to remember those things and
that just takes a lot of practice and
exposure uh chinese is difficult
obviously because you have to learn the
writing system and you have to learn
the tone so every language has its
difficulties but by and large the closer
the language is to your own language
group or to a language you already know
obviously the easier it's going to be
easier means you're going to learn
faster
but if you're enjoying the process
so it takes longer you enjoy it it
doesn't matter
it's a challenge i mean i see it as a
challenge
the more the language
you learn the bigger the challenge and
the more interesting you can get as well
right it's a bit like if you go for a
walk a hike in the woods
and your only concern is to reach the
finish line
you're not going to enjoy the forest
indeed
so you go on a shorter walk a longer
walk spanish is a shorter walk
chinese is a longer walk but if you
enjoy the process it doesn't matter but
you should be realistic as to the amount
of time it takes
okay on to my third question you you
talked about technology and how language
learning has become easier through
things such as mp3s and ipods and and
whatever ipads or whatever and what's
your opinion an experience of classroom
based language teaching and do you think
the way languages are taught in school
should be reformed you think that for
example they could make use better use
of technology
well let me quote a few
sort of facts i read once
on the internet that in new brunswick
which is the only bilingual province in
canada as you know
uh in the
french in the english language school
system
they teach french from grade 1
and they teach 30 minutes a day of
french
and they found that after 12 years
the average level of oral proficiency of
the graduates of the new brunswick
english language school system
the the
the number of students who achieved what
they called intermediate oral
proficiency
was 0.66
wow
wow i imagine that there are more people
than that who have a francophone parent
in other words the school system was
essentially irrelevant
in terms of the goal and i think if you
look at the english language school
system most
kids if they're not in french immersion
after six eight depending on the
province however many years they
graduate and they're not capable of
speaking french
and i gather that the same is true in
the us as far as spanish instruction so
that's at one end of the spectrum on the
other hand i attended a meeting of the
american uh
whatever it's called a c
association of teachers of foreign
language and i met some excellent people
down there i met one lady chinese lady
in her late 50s who was using the iphone
in her classroom
to help teach
chinese characters so i am sure that
there are many innovative teachers in
the system who are using technology
my over my reaction overall
has been that the educational
establishment
language teachers in our schools or for
that matter for that matter uh the whole
esl program for immigrants
that the
major motivation of the practitioners
the teachers there is to protect the
existing system
and to protect the dominant position of
the classroom
to protect the idea that it's the
teacher who says the curriculum the
teacher decides what people are going to
do and they're
largely reluctant
and even those teachers who want to
wander away from that are prevented from
doing so by
the system by
the bureaucracy by the language school
director so and maybe for the parents
who who want
the conventional they want to see their
kids tested on something
so you know in the case of french
instruction in english canadian schools
kids are tested and some kids do well
because in school some kids do well in
math and some kids do poorly and they'll
be tested as i'm sure in new brunswick
i'm sure the brighter kids did well on
the french test year after year after
year and at the end of 12 years they
couldn't speak french so so i think
there's some fundamentally
things that we have backwards in
language instruction one of the things
that i think is wrong
is is trying to get people to produce
the language too early
and then correcting them all the time
i don't think it's helpful
i think they're far
it's far better to focus on
understanding and finding ways to allow
the kids to enjoy the language and they
get it wrong they get it wrong what does
it matter that
so and so student in new brunswick
either did well or didn't do well in
these tests on you know
the subjunctive or conjugating verbs if
at the end of the 12 years it can't
speak anyway
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter so
yeah i think there's some real issues uh
but i think more and more
uh
even in the classroom if the mo if the
learner isn't motivated he's not he or
she's not gonna learn so so no i think
what's wrong is that they focus on
getting people used to language too
early
i think you need a lot of understanding
you need to focus on comprehension
understanding which can be done for kids
you know they can watch cartoons movies
find books for them to read uh things to
listen to and don't force them to try
and speak until they until they want to
but at first parents don't want that
they want to see the little kid say
something in french then there because
the little
you know whatever can say something so i
i hope that that changes
okay very good i'm hopeful
i'm not hosting insights
yeah
okay steve well before we finish off
this interview um do you have any
additional tips to language learners or
maybe um some some suggestions that you
would like to make to people
well i think language learning is is
very much a personal journey
and so
and the the uh
the number one issue is motivation
so if people really want to learn a
language then they have to take charge
they have to find
the method of learning that they like
the best
because if they like that method of
learning they will put in enough time
and ultimately
in order to succeed in language learning
you have to put in the time
you're gonna you're only gonna put in
the time if you're motivated if you find
different ways of learning that you like
you know
to me is listening and reading i don't
do much flashcarding i don't you know
don't like i'm not that concerned about
speaking until i have a certain
foundation in the language this is a
method that's worked for me but it might
very well be that other people have no
interest in reading no interest in
leading in listening so they have to
find their own path
but it's important to find the path that
works for you so that you enjoy it so
you put in the time because if you enjoy
it and you put in the time you will
succeed
well thank you so much steve these were
very interesting insights and i hope
people are going to have enjoyed this
interview thanks for your time
it was fantastic speaking to you okay
thank you
you